fixing trouble is
that's Spongebob Squarepants Broadway
musical which is expected to receive a
Tony Award nomination this morning the
children's onra could dominate this
year's nominees Harry Potter and the
cursed child and frozen are also in the
mix announcing this year's nominees only
on CBS this morning our Leslie Odom jr.
who won a Tony for his role in Hamilton
and katharine McPhee who's now starring
in waitress on Broadway let's go to
Lincoln Center in New York good morning
everyone and welcome to the 2018 Tony
Award nominations we are coming to you
live from New York Public Library for
the performing arts in New York City to
announce the nominees for the 72nd
annual Tony Awards and now for this
year's nominees the nominees for Best
Performance by an actor and a leading
role in a play are Andrew Garfield
Angels in America tom hollander
travesties Jamie Parker Harry Potter and
the cursed child parts 1 & 2 and Mark
violence fair in fairness farinelli
farinelli in the king Denzel Washington
Eugene O'Neill's The Iceman Cometh
the nominees for Best Performance by an
actress in a leading role in a play are
Glenda Jackson Edward Albee's three tall
women condole ever shod Saint Joan
Lauren rid laughs children of a lesser
God Amy Schumer meteor shower the
nominees for Best Performance by an
actor in a leading role in a musical are
Harry Hatton Patton my fair lady
Joshua Henry Rodgers and Hammerstein's
carousel Tony Shalhoub the band's visit
mm-hmm Ethan Slater Spongebob
Squarepants the musical the nominees for
Best Performance by an actress in a
leading role in a musical are Lauren
Ambrose my fair lady
hayley Kilgore once on this island
lashon's summer the Donna summer musical
Katrina link the band's visit Taylor
loud Ehrman Mean Girls
and Jessie Mueller Rodgers and
Hammerstein's carousel the nominees for
Best revival of a play are Angels in
America Edward Albee's three tall women
Eugene O'Neill's The Iceman Cometh lobby
hero travesties
[Applause]
for the survival of a musical are my
fair lady once on this island Rodgers
and Hammerstein's carousel the nominees
for best play are the children
farinelli and the king Harry Potter and
the cursed child parts 1 & 2 junk in
Latin history for morons the nominees
for Best Musical are the band's visit
frozen Mean Girls SpongeBob SquarePants
the musical there are a few more
nominations to get to this morning but
for all of you watching CBS this morning
we are going to send it back to Nora
John and Alex will see you all on June
the 10th nice to get a shout out of
junior CBS this morning contributor
Jamie wax is here to break down the
competition Jamie good morning good
morning
so not often that Edward Albee and Tony
Kushner are alongside SpongeBob's not in
the same categories Mean Girls and
spongebob are leading with the most
number of nominations our Charlie did
that well well I I mean not to take away
from the creativity behind those two
shows but the true answer is lack of
competition I mean this with 30 shows
eligible this season it's the lowest
number of eligible plays in any Broadway
season in over ten years to put that in
perspective 10 musicals premiered on
Broadway this season as opposed to 21
last season Harry Potter the most
expensive play in the history of
Broadway I think it's what 68 million
dollars that's 10 nominations so money
well spent money very well spent I have
to say this experience as many critics
has written already is magical it's hard
to be cynical about this play as much as
you want to be there was a father behind
me who said there's nothing
theme park about this it's not corny at
all and it's not it is dazzling visually
to the point that I feel bad for ever
saying I can't believe my eyes before
some of these effects they have but at
the heart of it it's a very
well-constructed fast-moving play that
moves through a running time of over
five and a half hours beautifully about
being a parent and deep regret and what
your destiny is they're big issues in
this play it's not the only one clocking
in at a few more hours than then a movie
your average movie Angels in America is
this way seven hours in 30 minutes this
is very good you know you did this
wonderful piece about people getting
away from their screens the theater is a
great place to do that please turn your
phone off leave it at home but it's
incredible to see long-form storytelling
doing so well two plays that make the
Iceman Cometh look short at three hours
and 50 minutes and people really getting
lost and absorbed in these great stories
for the theater it's so it's a wonderful
thing in the age of short attention
spans Disney's frozen got three
nominations well for them that's right I
mean I think that's low I think they
were probably hoping for more but they
got a lukewarm response the truth about
frozen is they're breaking records at
the st. James theater they don't need
the Tony nominations it's nice to have
them people forget that years ago wicked
did not win the Tony for Best Musical it
didn't do very well at the Tony's in
general except for some performances and
other other recognition and it didn't
need it obviously it's a juggernaut
still performing incredibly well well I
am excited to see how Andrew Garfield
does in nomination that's he's Fantasia
big fan Jamie thank you as always for
the inside scoop Sara Bareilles and Josh
Groban will host a 72nd annual Tony
Awards you can watch them Sunday June
10th at 8/7 central right here on CBS